my name is Alan cavity I'm a data
scientist and my presentation today is
on my book called functional data
workflow which will be published by
Wolfram media
my name is Alan cavity I'm a data
scientist statistician my background is
in engineering actually uh the title of
the talk is a tour of functional data
workflow the book the videos the coding
camp so this is the book that Stephen
Wolfram just approved for publication in
Wolfram media this is a book that we
were working on for about five years
based on our work at the Veterans
Administration the University of
California and I'll tell you a little
bit more about it so that's a book title
practically the subtitle is practical
methods without time-motion UX case
study where u X means user experience
that's a field in itself I'll tell you a
little bit the what motivated this book
and how the chapters and content in it
there's most of the book is focused on
one particular a case study that comes
from healthcare and then you know really
the the enabling factor is that we can
use a functional programming and
pipelining to make the codebase a lot
smaller than it would be otherwise and
then finally we talked about the
aspirational part which is creating the
tutorial videos and the coding camp so
the motivation is basically that many
books on data science are pretty
episodic in nature basically there's a
technique or a method that you want to
showcase and each chapter is essentially
independent from each other this book is
a bit different in which this is an
end-to-end coverage in all the data
analysis I was the lead data analyst for
many years of Veterans Administration so
essentially this book shows you how to
go from almost the very beginning to DM
in terms of importing data cleaning
indexing the statistical methodology and
even how to normalize the data yes we
hope at the end of the year I can share
some of the chapters if of wolfram
agrees to it because they're ready but
there's some cleanup stuff so hopefully
by the end of the year so it's basically
an entire arc of all the data analysis
coverage that we need to do including
the prep work which is very important
the reason it's significant is because
the data actually came from a large data
set and
multiyear studies that we conducted at
the Veterans Administration and
University of California so that led to
actually some measurement that we got
from this from this methodology and also
for some health IT prototyping the the
word arrived because of the results that
we got from it
part of the motivation was also to
showcase the Wolfram language to do data
so for example my work got considerably
easier when the functionality in version
10 came out so from version 9 to version
10 it was almost like a getting whole
new language where queries that would
take one page or more suddenly were
reduced by you know a factor of five or
even ten because of Association and the
query functionalities so particularly
for you know temporal data analysis most
most of what I'm gonna show you is a
temporal data oriented so the Wolfram
language lead to some amazingly compact
codes that would operate a pipelining so
I really want to make use that the
Wolfram language is a terrific language
for doing our data so the intended
audience is for data scientists and you
know professionals in this field
hopefully certainly grad students and I
think that some advanced undergraduates
could also get it it's not really meant
for beginners really because the
prerequisites are you sort of have to
know a little bit about functional
programming and you should have some
exposures to the Wolfram language so the
topics that are covering the book are
you know we go through the entire thing
that even the metadata management and
how we use google spreadsheets for
example to do what agile cycle in which
we develop the data dictionaries for
example online as we were actually doing
the the study now nothing was given to
us we couldn't afford a DBA none of the
data was indexed we had to come up with
everything for ourselves so it goes
through the entire arc of IO
indexing statistical analysis
visualization and even the results
management this book per se is not
really focused on that mathematics it's
the or even the statistics to be honest
there is some statistics of course but
there's nothing about machine learning
there's nothing about Big Data really in
this chapter except for one chapter and
I'll tell you about these excursion
chapters that I peppered in all over the
book so for example there is one chapter
which was
a very recent FICO of the credit rating
company they have a explainable machine
learning a challenge with like 10,000
rows of data so I used that and added
that that's a little bit more
mathematical but it's really not the
focus so yeah so the excursion chapters
are designed to basically be
self-contained sometimes they tell you
little bits and pieces about how to use
Mathematica but basically you know then
you could take em or leave em
essentially they're self-contained
things okay the functional code library
so that I have an appendix which is a
set of utilities it's mostly a set of
functions and operators that are mostly
like one-liners and that really
showcases the power of the language when
you see how quickly you can do some of
these some of these development here let
me open up let's see if this works so
this is basically my it's it's not the
finished product okay but this is this
is sort of my code and just to give you
some example of the kinds of functions
that are in here these are all basically
like yeah related to associations and
data sets okay but for example or you
know things to do with the time objects
data objects and so on so you can see
how small most of these functions are I
mean it kind of avoided doing like unit
testing for most of these things because
they're so stable once I wrote them
there's very little work that needs to
be doing in terms of maintenance purely
because of their small size okay so I'm
not gonna go into this in detail so let
me close this actually maybe we if
there's time I can get back to it
alright so I think we covered most of
these oh then the final sort of feature
of this is that we're gonna be using the
Wolfram data repository to manage most
of this data currently sitting in
Wolfram cloud I'm sorry in Google Drive
basically so most of this data and the
code can be shared to Google Drive but
the advantage of the rule from data repo
is I think you'll be able to query some
metadata let's get through all right so
let's show you some of these are
actually here while I was working on the
slide show I realized that you know I'm
gonna import some a couple of chapters
so I want to show you some of the
difference because people don't
understand that the the distinction
between querying on data sets versus
querying the raw associations okay so
here's an example where I'm importing
there's something like 30 chapters here
I'm importing the first three for
example okay so the first thing I'm
doing is essentially creating an
association where I'm giving the chapter
numbers and then the the values are in
an association those are the keys and
then the values are the paths that I'm
going to import so this is the query
okay I start off with filenames and then
I grab the first three so that's a query
and then we do an association map which
does nothing in this particular case
because really the hard work is just
taking key map and I'm gonna strip out
it basically starts off with this as the
input and then I just basically split it
up by the path components and then of
course I do another I take the last
component of that then I split it by the
dot up sorry the the period and then I
grab essentially the chapter number from
that okay so this is how you would query
associations so this shows that you
don't necessarily need data set per se
but you do have to have all sorts of
queries so what does querying on data
set bring to you well it's a wrapper
that sort of does formatting for you
there's a type system built into it and
it also lets you do query up it lets you
compose queries very nicely in terms of
the syntax so you can see that basically
what am i lighting here is the same as
the what's above here it's exactly the
same thing but you can see that the
syntax is a little bit more compact and
often you don't have to wrap things
inside the the keyword query alright so
the chapter header is basically I have
some introductory chapters and I'm gonna
label the Excursion ones in green then
you know what I think is you know the
key thing for data scientists to
understand is like before you get to the
machine learning there's a lot of prep
work yeah so there's a lot of these
chapters and again these are cumulative
right they just you sort of need chapter
four in order to go and they're
progressive okay so a lot of these
chapters are about sort of like indexing
and normalizing the data then there's a
set of analysis chapters and this is
really the you know the statistics and
visualizations proper and again except
for the excursion chapters are sort of
like self-contained sort of things and
then like I said like there's a
concluding chapters and an appendix that
includes the code libraries so I have a
code library that is the utilities that
I just showed you and plus there's a
project specific code library okay I'll
open these laters if we if
we have time to actually show you the
chapters themselves but I just want to
get through the slide show zero okay so
the the study is significant because
it's based on a study called quantifying
EHR usability to improve clinical
workflow EHR being electronic health
records the significance of latif these
are open a bowl here so as part of a
series of study that we did for about
six years it's interdisciplinary so it
relates to operations research clinical
informatics usability human factor
analysis the idea is to measure doctors
workflow with time at task and then also
computer use what functions did I use
and as part of that navigational
efficiency you know how long would it
take a doctor to order a medication
something like that yeah and then we
have to do this at two different sites
that use two different computer systems
and two different institutions with
completely different workflows so you
can see that that was the hard part
actually yeah so we published a paper
last year I was the lead on that journal
biomedical informatics if you want to
get the details on the methods the point
of the book is not about these methods
or even the results okay it's about
really but the software and creating
these PI points so the significance is
that it's a real-world data set it's not
a toy data set there's a lot of it's not
particularly large it's less than a
gigabyte I believe of raw data
keep in mind raw data was actually
videos and all sorts of image capturing
screen capture that's all identifiable
data so it's not even exported outside
of it's in a VA firewall a lot of human
coding was needed to get you know
discrete behaviors and so on I'll
explain a little bit of that but I could
get like you know we shared these
results with various Veterans
Administration national initiatives to
improve the health IT they really like
the results and in fact it was even
cited in Congress and then we actually
use some of these results to do some hid
redesign
here's an example of how much data was
collected the vertical axis is the
number of days it took us about almost
three years of data collection the red
is like a Veterans Administration in San
Diego the the Q's are the visit ID
identifiers basically the clinical
visits each visit is basically one
doctor one patient for primary care and
some specialties so maybe like 50 doctor
sixty doctors I forget exactly and each
doctor would see something like five to
six patients
on average let's say right so but each
visit was basically in one room okay so
this is just to show you how much
Radford was involved and if you don't do
this you don't have the data okay all
right so the data is divided in two I'm
gonna show you some of these data layers
here so for example here's an example of
how you can use cloud tools this is a
Google spreadsheet where the showing
some markers related to clinical codes
for Diagnostics and these are ICD codes
and we would define these as we went
along we didn't have these from the
start so these are data dictionaries
that we would actually have meetings and
while we would do the meetings we would
say are these are these columns
sufficient to spell out these data
dictionaries and if somebody or team was
very widely distributed we have multiple
faculty at various universities we would
be on call and we could all Co edit
these spreadsheets right so rather than
hiring a DBA to do the schema hello
tribe we would actually create these
spreadsheets and then of course you have
a lot of hard work at analysis time
because none of this data is really a
schema ties or typed but basically this
is the kind of stuff that we'll work on
so this is an example of a data
dictionary here's an example of some
okay so so this all this all these data
sets are in Google Drive currently as I
mentioned so it's a tree right none of
these are really there are not tables in
a database but basically at the end you
have branches of data and then you have
individual like CSV files so that's how
simple it is and each CSV file depends
really on the data layer but essentially
everything is generated as a tree I'm
gonna skip some of the details regarding
we actually got it but there was a lot
of human coding involved a lot of video
review and things of that nature so
here's an example of a human coded
clickstream files in other words a
person had to sit there and hand code
every single mouse click with what are
they actually doing on the computer
right and so these are also ragged so
these are very semi structured pieces of
data you have a timestamp and then you
have some markers that are introduced by
the recording software called Maury that
is a pretty common software we used to
do these kinds of data captures but then
the humans have to go through the human
coders would additionally tag other
pieces of information so you can see
that this is actually like pretty
in terms of a CSV and then so we have
these data indexes here so here's an
example again this basically mirrors the
file system yeah so this actually just
shows basically just the folder level
things not the actual data so you don't
seem to see individual CSVs but
basically you can think of at the leaf
nodes here there's almost like a hundred
if there's 200 visits you would have 200
files associated with each one of the
leaf nodes I'm sorry that's and by the
way this is basically like a one-line
function to mirror the filesystem into
this okay which i think is a pretty
incredible you can do these recursive
queries and they're very fast and here's
an example the data dictionaries so you
know I like what I learned in the five
years is that it helps to just organize
all your project data into one tree
essentially if you do that then it's
allows you to keep track of where things
are you can just look just kind of you
know key into the branch that you want
much more quickly than if you have
everything scattered around okay so
here's a here's the actual need of that
here's a figure that we published this
is in the journal biomedical informatics
this is what we actually collected this
is an example from one example visit and
this is the kind of data that we
collected so in part a we have mouse
path activity so basically you know the
XY coordinates of the mouse so this is
for you know 30 minute visit during a 30
minute visit the doctor may or may not
be actually using the computer right
there probably with the patient they're
doing physical exams but when they're in
front of the computer you can tell when
when they are because the mouse is
moving yeah so when it's static like
this they're probably with the patient
and so on right so the mouse is moving
then there is mouths activity now this
is human coded and it's human coded into
a set of discrete behaviors so in other
words what are they actually doing on
the computer which window are they in
are they in the notes are they order
entry consoles and so forth so that's
this channel here then we also have what
they actually typed and we have to di
Denton
so we have to normalize a way what they
actually typed into a set of characters
for example what we really wanted to
know is how much numeric data are they
entering in the notes because numeric
data is probably something that they
copy/paste it from like a menu or system
and that's something that should have
been automatic but instead they're
actually copy pasting it manually
potentially leading to errors so we
really just wanted to discriminate
alphanumeric versus control keys and I
then we have eye tracking with eye
tracking device to see did I skip some
information that turned out to be very
difficult actually and then we have a
set of based on room video we have who's
speaking that's these channels here
actually let's say yeah so this is who's
speaking when so literally we have
microphones and from the audio somebody
had to tag the doctors talking the
patient is talking and so forth and then
we have some additional information
eventually you lead to these sort of
continuous behaviors and that's how you
do the time of tasks essentially once
you have this and we also look this is
actually one of the most interesting one
is the nonverbal this is what what is
the doctor actually looking at blue is
when they're looking on the computer
monitor Green is when they're looking at
the patient you know pink is when
they're looking at the medications or
paper and there's also a physical exam
and so forth so for this particular
doctor you can see first of all there's
a lot of back-and-forth but when you've
kind of mentally integrated these guys
are looking at in a 30 minute visit
they're spending 15 minutes or more
looking at the computer the probably
they're still talking with the patient
but you know that's that's how intense
the workflow is for a lot of these
doctors because I have 10 minutes left
so I wanted to get to some of these
functional patterns you're kind of skip
this the idea is that with functional
programming often you can just use
operators you don't have to carry the
arguments with you most of the time you
can do things that are for example like
in in databases you do joins but with
hierarchical data you can do merge and
on the key/value dictionaries and when
you do merges you can actually pass a
function unlike join so when you do a
joint basically the keys are already
defined for you but in merge is a much
more powerful idea so that's an example
of an operator that takes a function as
an input in addition to the data and you
can create some very very fancy things
so this is more like computer science
thinks this is all spelled out in the
books I'm not really going to get into
it but it basically leads to much more
scalable and usable queries that you can
that you can change if as needed and
like I say I think most people are not
aware of this but basically the Wolfram
language I work with people they used
are a biostatistician use R and another
programmer use Python and the features
that are in the Wolfram language lets
you do things in much less time
basically
fewer lines of code much more easier to
read and so forth you know provided that
you're that you're from it took me a
good 10 years to move from like a C and
C++ mentality as an engineer to using
the to thinking in terms of functional
programming once you make that switch is
very difficult to go back okay because
it's just because of the efficiency yeah
and now we're really high light among
them is just you can think in terms of
these query pipes basically where you
have you know these data flow languages
are basically you have these directorís
likely graphs where you have input data
at the initial stage and then you create
various intermediate stages of data
until you finally get a final data set
pretty much like git commits essentially
it's the same sort of thing
yeah okay so wanna think I really wanna
emphasize you know instead of having a
function for every every detailed piece
of thing you can do by using pipelines
you can actually create sentences of
functions basically right so you can let
you use a patterns essentially and it's
much more flexible way of doing it
really reduces the number of functions
that you really need I probably use a a
very small set of core functions that
are that are generic kind of programming
functions but you can combine and very
flexibly to create these programming
types and of course the book is full of
examples around this so let me show you
some of this probably have a few minutes
left here so here are some example
queries okay so this is you know from
the index in other words even this is
without prior to even importing the data
this is how you would actually create
this is basically a census of how much
memory each data layer takes up okay and
this is it this is the entire query the
index that was that tree that I showed
you earlier okay so basically there's
just like in a few lines of code you can
do some significant analysis okay again
try this in Python you know get back to
me you know he in a couple of pages
later here's an example where you can
kind of scale up these queries to do the
same query on different population
groups for example okay so this is an
example of an asset what's called an
asset survey task load index so you can
do this and you group it by this is the
VA side this is the University of
California side and you can you're doing
essentially the same query you're just
doing this quantile sort of a statistic
here but but the point is now you can do
it from multiple populations with the
same query then you just say all
and then you specify the query at the
second level and you have it and it
works like a charm and you can see how
small the query is itself here's one
where we do demographics and you can
kind of create these dashboards you know
so easy to communicate results when you
do this rather than having sort of
either very basic ok nothing on towards
the end of this okay so I'll just give
you one more outer products so here's an
example where I created an operator
called outer that can do that works for
key value pairs and here's how you would
do it you can actually manage both the
key pairs and the values and now here so
scatterplots + correlation and this is
it this is the actual query now of
course I have to do some intermediate
results here but basically most of these
queries are kind of like a couple of
miles long ok if you don't want to sort
of language see if there's more do it
okay the rest is basically just things
that you're gonna find in the book no
matter what but just to impress you you
know again this is really just to again
highlight that it only takes like a few
lines of code to make all these yeah so
basically this is the bottom there's the
kinds of things that we actually publish
yeah the time of tasks how much time
does it take you to you know on average
how much doctors look at the computer
versus how much do you look at the
patient by specialty by site and so on I
can probably stop here actually because
basically the end is that once we
publish the book I want to do a set of
tutorial videos where I'll take a query
and I'm gonna break it down with echoes
so that you can show the seeker the
intermediate results that should be
fairly easy and then we want to do
something that's in between a MOOC and a
coding camp III favor coding camps
because you can work in teams and you
can work on real-world problems which i
think is gonna be the future of
instruction and education rather than a
MOOC which is kind of like online and
it's sort of like you know
individualized work yeah so basically
that's it
you